schools used to look like this
classrooms packed with students
lunchrooms full of loud conversations
and teachers just trying to catch a
break in the lounge
it's a scene that now looks primed for
the spread of the coronavirus
you have a lot of people together in one
space for a long period of time
without mass we don't know if the
ventilation's any good
and with activities like shouting those
are all the ingredients for a super
spreading event
that's why now school looks very
different
many schools are only partially open for
in-person learning
and others are still fully remote it's
not business as usual
everything has changed elia valdez has
been back in her classroom since october
i was very concerned about health issues
i knew that this was the best thing for
students to go in physically
because that's hands down they will
always perform better
with the virus still spreading and
schools reopen safely
what are the risks of catching covet
there and how to control measures like
wearing a mask
or increasing ventilation change that
picture
let's look at the classroom lunchroom
and break room
classrooms are one place where you have
a lot of people in the room for a long
period of time that's pretty risky
this is particularly true for adults or
older kids
age really matters in terms of
transmission
both in terms of acquisition of covin
as well as transmission of sarcoscopic
to the viruses cause the skin
studies have found that compared with
adults children might be infected less
often
are less likely to show severe symptoms
and are less
likely to be hospitalized for severe
infection
[Music]
that said the risk isn't zero even for
younger kids
we know that the virus is transmitted in
a variety of ways
large droplets exchanged at close range
small droplets
lingering in the air and indirectly
through contact with a contaminated
surface
if somebody who's infected with covid
comes into a classroom and there's no
control measures in place then they're
sitting there breathing and talking and
they're releasing
virus into the air think of the virus
forming a small cloud
in front of the infected person larger
virus-laden droplets expelled from their
nose or mouth would fall nearby
while the smaller droplets would float
further away and that's just from
talking normally
by shouting and screaming and being
emotional you can give these droplets
superpowers
make them smaller which we call aerosol
and can fly
further 10 20 feet in some cases
it's gonna kind of fill the room
eventually especially if that room is
poorly ventilated
and then everyone else in that room is
going to be exposed to it will be forced
to breathe it
but this picture changes dramatically
when control measures are put in place
experts say the most important one is
masking
with masks on everyone the infected
person would release
less virus into the air and the others
would have some protection against the
virus that remains
i would say the second most important
thing is to ensure good ventilation
of the classroom it could be as simple
as opening some doors and windows
doing so helps replace the air inside
the classroom
bringing in clean air from outside
that can remove or reduce the virus in
the room
lowering the risk of transmission
physical distancing is another way to
mitigate risk
the cdc used to recommend six feet but
it's since
changed it to three there's not a magic
number for safe versus unsafe but the
farther apart people
are the better so that they're kind of
out of each other's directly exhaled
breath
a study of massachusetts public schools
found that case
rates in schools maintaining three feet
of distance were similar to those in
schools using six
feet prevention
gets more complicated in the lunchroom
so in the lunchroom setting
it's virus heaven the virus is in
paradise because there's so many ways
to infect noses and mouths that's
because to eat
students need to take off their masks
taking away a key control measure
to compensate experts recommend adding
portable air cleaners with hepa filters
if possible
the portable air cleaner works by
pulling air through it
and passing it through a really high
quality filter that filters out and
removes
all the aerosols that are in the air and
all the virus that they might contain
and then out the other side of the
portable air cleaner comes nice
clean virus free air
in the teacher break room cleaning the
air is also really important
because it's only adults adults of
course breathe more
than kids do and produce probably even
per breath produce more aerosols and so
let's say someone's sick well an adult
is probably going to release more virus
into the air and the other adults in
that room are going to be breathing
more of that air compared to kids
surface cleaning and hand washing are
also important here
just maybe not as critical as was
initially thought
excessive attention to surface cleaning
is taking away time and energy
from cleaning the air which is going to
be more important for reducing the risk
of transmission in schools
for teachers vaccination is the latest
control measure
and most states are giving k-12
educators priority
i just recently got my vaccine so that
makes me feel a lot better
even with a vaccine limiting teacher
interactions with students is important
what can you do because it's still
unclear if vaccination stops
transmission
and studies have shown adults are more
likely to transmit the virus than
younger kids
for whom vaccines aren't authorized yet
i would always greet my students
at the door um hello how are you come on
in you know sit down and some of them
will give me hugs
as well des high five uh now it's like
you know elbow or no social distance
remember
you know we can't uh get close to one
another experts say the key is not
relying on any one control strategy
masking distancing ventilation
vaccination
and testing all have a role to play in
how schools reopen
so to try and keep everything all at
once and that laundry list
in place it's probably going to be very
frustrating for many people
and i think if you had to do one thing
it's probably going to be wearing that
mask